fondons merci madame mais la balle est
un monsieur julien aubert
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur un
récent reportage sur m6 présenté par
bernard de la villardière dans le cadre
de l'émission dossier tabou à dévoiler
la face cachée de l'islamisme en france
il montre que par électoralisme
certaines municipalités n'hésite pas à
courtiser les salafistes il montre que
si la république ne reconnaît ne salarie
aucun culte d'autres puissances
étrangères le font à notre place
finançant par là même une idéologie qui
sape la république il montre
qu'aujourd'hui en france la liberté
d'informer peut se heurter à des nervis
sur le terrain mais surprise pendant que
la france subventionne des écoles
coraniques 5000 élèves dans une
cinquantaine d'établissements et se
montre d'une coupable indulgence avec
les imams radicaux on s'acharne à
décrédibiliser les lanceurs d'alert
bernard devy de la villardière a ainsi
été accusé d'avoir truqué son reportage
et une semaine plus tard le parquet de
paris ouvre une enquête préliminaire
contre eric zemmour pour apologie du
terrorisme mettre sur le même plan eric
zemmour à dieudonné il fallait y penser
comment expliquez vous monsieur le
ministre que l'on soit davantage
inquiété lorsqu on dénonce l'islam
radical que lorsqu'on bafoue la
république dans des prêches des vidéos
et des pratiques qui défie l'identité
culturelle de la france il faut écraser
le mal quand il est encore temps une
étude menée par l'ifop et l'institut
montaigne a révélé début septembre que
28% des français musulmans place la
charia au dessus des lois de la
république cela fait un million de
personnes potentiellement réceptive aux
discours des islamistes
il est en train de se créer sous nos
yeux une jeunesse salafistes en rupture
avec la communauté nationale une
jeunesse qui ne croient plus au projet
républicain monsieur le ministre quand
allez vous déclarer un moratoire sur la
création d'écoles coraniques hors
contrat tant que le péril islamiste ne
sera pas écartée quand allez-vous
prendre des mesures de précaution oblige
en l'islam de france à utiliser une
version revue et corrigée du corps en
expurger sourate qui servent de support
idéologique au djihadisme pour plagier
un futur candidat à la primaire prenez
garde à ce que la marianne d'aujourd'hui
ne devienne la femme voilée de demain la
parole internationaux ministre intérieur
il y a beaucoup de choses dans votre
question monsieur le député aux verts
qui appellent qu'on réponde sur les
principes et puis correspondent aussi
sur un certain nombre de sujets que vous
avez évoquées qui ne correspondent pas
tout à fait la vérité d'abord sur les
principes je vous rejoins volontiers la
république est une et indivisible n est
pas un ensemble de communautés c'est
l'appartenance à la communauté nationale
qui prévaut sur toutes les autres et
l'unité et l'indivisibilité de la
république sont des principes inscrits
dans la constitution
et nul ne peut évoquer en france qu'ils
soient musulmans ou qu'il appartient à
une autre religion ou à une appartenance
philosophico-politique une autre loi que
celle de la république et ceux qui sont
en charge de la gestion de la république
doivent veiller à l'application
rigoureuse et stricte de la loi et il
n'y a pas en tous les cas sur les bords
de cet hémicycle de différence entre les
différentes sensibilités je ne souhaite
pas qu'on laisse à croire qu'il en
existe parce que c'était une manière de
ne pas dire la vérité sur ce que sont
nos positionnements premier point
deuxième élément vous parlez des écoles
je vous rejoins complètement mais c'est
pas à nous qui cherchons à les contrôler
qu'il faut vous adresser c'est à la
majorité sénatoriale qui s'est opposé à
la proposition du gouvernement de
contrôler les écoles sous contrat donc
moi je vous propose je vous propose de
bien vouloir
interpeller vos amis politiques du sénat
en leur demandant les raisons pour
lesquelles ils se sont opposés à la
volonté que nous avions de contrôler les
écoles hors contrat le troisième point
sur lequel je voudrais insister si vous
dites que nous sommes insuffisamment
énergiques contre l'islamisme mais là
aussi monsieur le député au vert je veux
provoquer les faits je suis en charge de
la lutte contre l'islamisme radical au
mieux au ministère de l'intérieur avec
d'autres ministres qui agissent dans
leur domaine
quelles instructions ont été données au
préfet et quels résultats obtenons nous
j'ai donné instruction que dans chaque
département où il ya des imams qui
appelle et provoque au terrorisme des
procédures sont enclenchées par les
préfets eux mêmes au titre de l'article
40 du code de procédure pénale et c'est
ainsi que nous avons fermé 20 mosquées